so this talk is about accelerating
python code
and it's more for those people of you
who are have a scientific background not
really a software engineering background
where you're used to
use different programming languages all
the time anyway
it's for those
maybe coming from mathematics or physics
and
generating models to tackle a complex
problem
love that language python because it's
so simple so easy to use
and see there are problems in getting
the ideas to production code
myself I'm being a physicist with a
Applied Physics background
I'm happily worth Rosa for more than 20
years now working in different roles
there and development also management
I'm a python user since python 1.4 which
is a long time ago
and currently I'm
working on embedded electronics and have
a software stack running there which is
python based
I'm a Vim user
just to get me in the right category and
I do like the print function a lot
so what's the motivation that you have
here it's about python is the language
that we all are for prototyping
and as I said when it comes to getting
your ID in the product into production
there might be secure it might be
concerns from other people which are on
the way between you and your success in
doing so
being security concerns that you just
didn't do the authentication process
but all there is no matching matching
infrastructure for the workflows like
well will it run on windows then
and attitudes about the language itself
when people say you really want us to
use an interpreted untyped languages
that has deal issues
well the good news is there's low
hanging fruits to help us and we see
that
so what we're covering today what we're
not covering today
there will be there's not a machine
learning talk
there will be no chat GPT or GPT
whatever no agents and no Transformers
sorry for that
it's just plain python things numerical
issues that's that's all we do today
what we will be addressing is we give an
overview of the possible solutions to
speed up simple numerical calculations
to overcome Python's main limitations
right there
prepare a strategy for scaling an
execution model
and we're looking for a simple numerical
formula to do that with a notable
workload that we can create with that
which is well suited to
try to scale
on the path to very small from very
small systems to very very large systems
um
for the impatient and maybe for your
management the right thing is what you
can report when you get home everything
will be just better after that
so what about the theory that we use
we're using an a thing called the
mandelbrot set
to calculate I'm happy that at least at
the talks that I attended nobody used
that before at least this time
and
it belongs to the area of chaos and
fractals so what is the chaos
and the scientific sense mainly stands
for unpredictable behavior in systems in
complex systems
think of the butterfly effect probably
most of you know that that the wing of a
butterfly is somewhere in the world
might affect the weather on the very
other side of the world that might be a
very theoretical example
but it's gotten quite famous in that
area and there are structures
and they show very complex behavior and
very complex shapes
um can be found some in in natural
structures like we've seen here
in the photos and people worked on that
for a very long time to find simple
mathematical formulas
that help to describe that
so it's a very very complex structure
that we see right in the middle of the
Romanesco that vegetable
and if you were to to describe how that
looks
make a model that that describes it very
well it is very very complicated to do
and we find these structures in nature
all over the place and probably there is
no complex code in nature that resembles
that so there must be a much more simple
solution and there is
so there's one man that got famous
behind it which is Benoit report
he is a polish-born French American
mathematician he studied mathematics
both in France and the United States and
he had a broad interest in various
scientific topics if you look up his
work it's lots of areas where you
contributed
he is a very lucky guy being employed at
IBM at some time he became a fellow at
IBM which is Edge of every one of us
probably envies a lot
because that is you get a lot of money
that you can spend on things that you
think are important for the company and
for the future and IBM just supports you
in doing so so that that is really a
thing
because of that he was able to get to
significant Computing resources quite
early in his work
where no one else had any computers at
hand he was able to do so
and he was working on the idea or to
stood or to study roughness in nature
there was something really describing
the thing think of the clouds that you
see in the sky where it's just not the
circle or a distorted Circle it's
something very much more complex than
that or coastlines and he came up with
the idea to describe this thing as
roughness
and to find something easy describing
that roughness he was the one that made
the phrase fractal
to show these complex structures where
cell similarity is a thing where you
look at a large scale look in more
detail and find the same structure that
you've seen in the large scale in the
small scale again
but he was not the first one to do so he
was extending a work that is more than
100 years older
from the French mathematics for two and
Julia
and but he studied a
a specific subset of what the work
before was done
and that led to a set of numbers in the
complex plane that was named after him
the mandrel broad set
so what it looks like formula we can we
can do a formal definition of that and
the motherboard set is
starting with a number zero is that zero
being zero the next sum number you can
calculate like squaring that number and
add a number c to it
and he was using that
new interpretation based on the work of
artery and Julia then using the
coordinates and the complex plane for
the specific number to Edge to that
formula
so all these numbers that fulfilling a
Special Rule like those in iteration do
not blow up they do converge all those
numbers they belong to the mandrel broad
set
so let's have a look at some examples
for that
and there it's all gone
and I don't know why
let's see if we can find another
always have a backup
unpredictable outcome
it's literally named like that
so back again
well if you want to iterate that maybe
in your hat that formula then it says
take a number that comes to your mind
and update that number by squaring it
and adding that original number to it
repeat it a few times and see where
everything goes
so let's do that write a little python
function that supports us call it
calculate
be a bit responsive
and it all it gets are two parameters
one is that number that we are thinking
of
and we'll limit things a bit when we're
starting it depending on what what might
be going on
we start off with using that very number
as x0 is write the formula by squaring
it adding the original value and print
the outcome
and we're looking at that for
some numbers that immediately come to
our mind like well those numbers
0 1.5 these things
and see where things really go when when
iterating that function
and there's things missing in this let
me see if there
we can have that again
that's not looking too well
I don't know what happens here really
issues in loading the data
locally
let me see if
go there maybe things will better
sorry for that
you know if you try these things days
before the talk over and over again
hours before that things just work and
then you're standing here and things no
longer work
for whatever reason that I don't know
okay that's looking better we're coming
there
there we are
so here I have some tabs that show
outcomes from these numbers that come to
our mind like starting with zero what
might want to help what will happen then
well everything stays at you you
squaring zero outcome will be zero
adding zero nothing fancy happens then
you're going for number one
that you can do in your ad you using one
squaring it it's one adding one is two
next iteration will be squaring two it's
going to four adding one it's five and
things will explode up quite
quickly really
next thing to show is well let's half it
down when we see one is larger than zero
getting any larger will probably also
blow up so let's get a little a little
smaller than that like say use a half
and then yet still we see
things tend to blow up again we are at
10 to the 32 in the last number that's a
lot
let's have it another time
one over four that looks as though we
can get some conversion here not quite
sure let's have a few more numbers to
look at well yeah that pretty much looks
as though there might be an end when
repeating this
let's get some further
having it again or looking at a few more
numbers probably it is getting somewhere
around probably half in the end not sure
you need to repeat a lot more
let's have a bit more and see what that
leads probably that is going to converge
as well
what about on the other side of the way
of our zero point minus
1.1.5 and that probably also is going to
converge quite quite good next swing
okay
will also converge minus a half probably
also converge
we probably get the idea minus one well
that's not expected right
but what if we use Square it on our head
things get clearer like minus one
squared that's that's one removing one
gets us to zero
squaring it will be zero removing one is
-1 again and we start from we start from
scratch that will lead us literally
nowhere
and if we move further down the road
then things get even more complicated we
see some minus where you see a positive
one minus values a positive one
that pretty much seems chaotic and you
can go on
minus two that will literally have a
attractive Point minus two square will
be four subtracting
the two will be two again and that will
literally leave you where you are
and one step further down the road and
things will explode again
so that is by playing in your head but
you still do not get the right idea how
everything looks like
let's do it graphically
the idea being to now iterate on the
complete real numbers plane and see how
the the outcome looks like in that case
and there we see all those areas
that are quite interesting actually we
have stable points
we have a bifurcation how it's called
that things split up being stable into
even more branches
and it's getting chaotic afterwards
but it's getting stable again
and chaotic afterwards that's quite
interesting
but the idea that mandelbrot had was to
extend this to the complex plane and see
where that where that leads
so let's
all we need to do is change the code so
it is not no longer working on real
numbers but on complex numbers get the
imaginary part in and try a lock with
that
so what about
the imaginary part being zero that gets
our bifurcation
diagram that we just saw
adding an imaginary part changes things
quite significantly
that's even more chaotic it's the same
things that we see going on we have
stable points
we have a splitting up in branches we
have chaotic regions
quite a thing going on
you can go on on the imaginary axis it's
getting chaotic earlier
and it's getting more complex and more
complex and even we see things are
totally blowing off if imaginary numbers
get larger and larger
on the other side
having negative imaginary numbers that
gets us some symmetry work that's
something that we've seen before so
there might be some symmetry involved
yet we still do not have the
a good idea of everything looks like
so let's have a look when we do an
animation on how these things develop
when we vary the imaginary numbers
here we have colorized all the real
numbers like a table of contents it's
the bifurcation diagram for the
imaginary part being zero
and what really happens if you do the
complex multiplication so that you have
a rotation in the complex plane
so multiplication of complex numbers
actually are a rotational process and to
visualize this I've added another
dimension
so like when the real axis on the x-axis
we have the real part
on the y-axis we have the outcome for
the imaginary part and if you iterate
all these things then we use the Z axis
the z-axis to to show where the
complex value the imaginary value will
end up
if we play the animation
then we might get an idea how these
things develop when saying when changing
the imaginary numbers that are involved
these are all the fancy things that you
can do with IPI volume by the way which
is quite a nice library to be using for
these things
and quite fast
but still when it comes to just seeing
the set of numbers that are involved we
don't have the right idea
so let's
we probably need to need another
approach
we had an idea now
how complex numbers involve in this
iteration how things change
but we still have not the right idea how
everything looks like so let's adjust
our implementation just a bit
this is the very naive the most naive
implementation you can think of in
Python if you start doing python then
probably that is what you would write
down at least that was
almost what I've written down years
years back
so what we're doing here is we create
based on some interesting parameters our
view
for the X and Y axis
standing for the real and the imaginary
part
so this here gives us a list of numbers
pretty much like numpy Lin space would
generate them
and then all you need to have and all
you need to to be doing is iterating the
complex plane with the imaginary parts
and the real Parts building the complex
number
use the c0 as a starting point and
the number that we're adding in our
iteration process squaring it adding the
number and have some conversion criteria
being checked where we know things will
explode
then we know the number of iterations it
took which we can add to our row of
complications ending up in our complete
set of implications of iterations our 2D
array and then we can have a look at how
this motherboard set really looks like
when colorizing it
for some reason I can't show the whole
thing but you get it but you get the
idea
so all the
pixels painted in Black here they do
belong to the mandelbrot set
and all the other colored areas just
show the number of iterations it took
until deciding that things will blow up
when it's writing
quite nice
complex features
fractal indeed
and a very very simple formula behind it
and on some machine that I worked on
that took four or seven seconds to
compute
well the next thing when it comes to
speeding up things we probably want to
prepare a bit and wrapping things you
know that refactoring thing and you see
there is different purposes in the cold
let's refactor them out give them the
meaning
and one thing that you can do is
immediately see that the center part the
really the the iterative process can be
directly wrapped into a function
and then apply the rest
and that took 3.6 seconds
that's interesting it's already a speed
up
anyone knows why
that's right exactly that's the thing
beforehand everything was in the global
context and if the python interpreter
starts to interpret our script
then he puts all the variables in the
global context and needs to find them
there
and if there's a function he starts to
bite compile it putting all the
variables there needed or addressed
there into that byte compiled and he
knows that they are in that scope no
longer needs to search for them in the
global space in the global school which
takes some time
so that's already a first step that
everyone can do
when you're used to do scripting use
functions and you will have a
significant a really significant
increase of speed
well the next thing we we have a look at
some implementation so we prepare some
benchmarking scenario
where we wrap all the code that is
necessary
into one single function that provides
us an API
so we know
whenever we need to come calculate the
monitor set we have some bounding box
described by this X-Men xmax y Min y Max
there is a parameter for Max iterations
we say that's where we stop
and there will be a resolution where we
say how many pixels we like to calculate
that we will see more often throughout
this talk
the next thing that we can imagine is in
the Wilson trick in the old days
everyone did
is can we benefit from symmetry we've
seen that mirroring reflection the top
part was exactly like the bottom part
and that's probably something that we
can address in Python quite easily and
quite elegant actually
by just using our func tools cache
decorator
and all we need to do here to benefit
from this is
in our
main function that is calculating
everything
wrap it by using the cache decorator
and afterwards using the absolute value
of our imaginary part
by doing that
the effect is that when this set of
parameters x y and Max iterations
occurs the first time then really the
function is executed and we have the
result but it's also stored in the cache
and as soon as it is retrieved the
second time then no longer is the
function calculated but just the result
that it's already known as retrieved
from the cache so that should give us a
significant
speed up by a factor of probably two
right
so let's see what where we are it's 2.6
seconds so it's a lot quicker but it's
not really
what we expected it's not half that
so any idea why that is the case
there is some sort of casual word it's
not the main problem here
there's an issue
there's a hint down below
and Miro talked about it in the talk
before it's floating Point Precision
issues
let's use some few numbers to illustrate
that the way that I create the axis like
numpulan space Urban space does it it's
like so
and if we get some numbers they look
very symmetric minus 1.25 plus 1.25 but
already the next number just matches at
the beginning at the very end they no
longer match
so it's not the parameter set that you
will find in the cache thus it will be
recalculated it's exactly what's
happening we have a lot of cash misses
with that
luckily we can correct it quite easily
and the idea is to just reverse the list
of numbers that we have inverted
and add them all together averaging them
so if there is an error in floating
Point numbers involved then there will
be symmetrical everywhere
and if we do that then we are correctly
benefiting from our symmetry
you see that I'll put the little trick
in here
and then we're at 2.1 seconds that's
almost half what we spent before so
that's the best thing we could do for
naive python code
that's specialized
there are ways to generalize this
a bit more complex
but it will be working
so I've made an a benchmarking engine
for this so that we can try all our
applications with different views
because maybe the results are just
depending on the workload so that's the
idea
and there is a GitHub repository showing
all these things or we'll post about
that later on so you can see all the
implementations in detail
and what I've done is running it on
a machine
all these different views being very
simple or more complex using all these
engines as a plugin
and here are the results
for the naive implementations and the
wraps and because of the nature of the
benchmarking engine using a function
approach we no longer have this naive
Global based implementation effect
anymore so that's why the naive inner
Funk and outer Funk thing are literally
the same numbers
but we see that naive caching and
optimized caching get us down and the
base view is the main Monday broad set
view that we've seen before and they are
more complex scenarios like a medium
View
or a slight view where things get
different
we think we will see the the results for
for other implementations later on
so for optimized implementations
the next thing that you probably want to
do is as we have a numerical problem use
numpy
things change drastically when doing so
numpy is a classical library of choice
to perform the array-based calculations
it gets you to the idea to no longer
work on a single number one by one but
using the complete array put it in our
iteration process and see where things
let things go
it uses optimized libraries behind the
scenes in the older days and on some
machines architecture still
they are Fortran based libraries like
open Blast for example
and on internal machines you can use the
MAF kernel Library which might be a bit
faster than that
so how do things change so now we have
the numpy Lin space that you're probably
all familiar with to generate our axis
and we create the complex array right
from the beginning by using our real
numbers
and adding and switching the the
direction of our imaginary numbers
multiplying by our complex number and
then we have a field of complex numbers
that covers the complete interesting
complex plane
and then we have the inner function
which pretty much looks like the the
naive implementation before but is
working on on a complete array and now
as we've seen that there are numbers
that explode quite quickly and will give
you overflow errors we need a strategy
just to work on the necessary subset and
that's what we're doing by a binary mask
we see where the convergence criteria is
fulfilled that makes our to-do list
and then we're just working on the
subset of the array
iterating
our formula
and
provide back and complete iterations
array afterwards for colorization
will that work
probably it will that gives her the
complete iteration process again
so The Benchmark results they change
and it roughly gives us a speed up of a
factor of two with not really much
change in it
you will have more benefit if things get
larger more complex than that
next thing that comes to mind is and
there is a very modern approach is
jitting
so can we jit it yes we can probably can
reach with it there are a number of of
things that you can use for that one
that immediately should come to your
mind is using Pi Pi
and that is
a different implementation it is an
implementation of the Python language in
a different way like C python is the
implementation that we use to use for
python in in C or jython is a variant
where everything has been done in in
Java Pi Pi is a very end implementating
it
the the Python language and using a jit
approach
and the approach is the idea behind this
is to to
when the code is executed get an idea
what's going on and using optimized
strategies instead
another approach is using number
and number can just be used to decorate
functions that are there it has a
tracing jit so it will also have a look
at what code is executed and what is
aimed for it we'll see
where things
might be parallelized
and use optimized machine code for that
it will use the code blocks that a c
compiler would be using to compile C
code and instead use that for running
your python code
and things do not change a lot so this
is the the naive implementation that we
had already with the three nested
follows this ugly thing
and all you need to do to accelerate it
is to
decorate it using numberjit
and that will give you a significant
speed up as we'll see in a moment
another idea is to start to think in
kernels like
switching the problem around no longer
having the idea to
iterate a whole array of things but to
have something that can be applied to
each and every element of the array
so you write a kernel we have to be a
bit more specific here telling number
about the data types that are involved
and then it can compile for you a very
optimized version that you can use
another new kid in town is Jax
pretty much aiming for the same thing
and
it belongs to the
tool set of of deep learning and machine
learning probably but for as we know for
all of this we knew we we do need
numerics
so
we probably want to have a look at that
as well I personally wasn't able to get
it running on the machine so that's why
sadly things will be missing on the
Benchmark but things are simple because
all the libraries that are evolving
today
will use the API that most of us are
familiar with already based on numpy so
that's that's already the best idea to
to look for those libraries that
implemented because the change will be
very very subtle as we see it's nothing
really
different here but just one line and we
could have done that in in numpy as well
because Jax doesn't allow In-Place
modifications
so we have to have a copy but that is
very very optimized
and The Benchmark results they are
stunning
the use of Pi Pi and numpy
and number and number vectorize they
bring you significantly down to our
reference
for the naive implementation around
three seconds so we are now at half a
second for the same thing and that does
not vary a lot with the workload so the
points you see in the diagrams they
hardly move but the scales on the axis
they do
and there are all of core
implementations and I have to be quick
with what I'm saying because of your
lacking time a lot
and the idea being that you have
multiple cores available in your
machines these days and python being
stuck with global interpreter lock Hardy
can use that
but there's ways to overcome this by
applying the divide and conquer
principle so that you can split up your
workload and our tool our formula that
we use is ideal for that
because no pixel is dependent on the
outcome on the other for other from from
any neighboring pixel so that's that's a
good thing and you simply split up the
work and have a sub process running for
you and there are various methods in the
python standard library that allow that
one being the olds being
multi-processing so you have a
multi-processing pool that helps you
doing that
and a more modern approach which is
concurrent futures
where you can choose between a threat
pool and a process pool
and if you look at the results in the
under Union you see a
pretty significant speed up by that as
well again we have here the the naive
code being at three seconds and it can
do all sorts of combinations of things
that we've seen before
to just let it run in parallel on the
number of calls that you have and it
will give you a significant feedback
speed up
many libraries allow you to execute that
code also on the GPU which is massively
parallel in that case same strategy you
need to think of getting to the idea to
um
have small functions working on a subset
of the of the data that you have
coupon is the thing that
is probably the best to start for NVIDIA
gpus it's from the context of Nvidia
and it resembles the numpy interface
again so it's a very very slight change
the whole code just doesn't change but
the namespace and then you can start off
accelerating a lot
number can do the same thing for you you
have a target for that that allows you
to compile the code
for the GPU from numpy import Cuda
kudajit
and then you have a kernel that you can
apply and will give you a significant
speed up
and there's things like pie torch that
again use the same API it's a pretty
good start
nothing really changes and you get there
and The Benchmark results they are
stunning
that gives you to near zero seconds it's
just and it happens
usually the first calculation that
you're starting they are costly
but after that things will get a lot
better so if you have repetitive work
workloads to do then you will benefit
strongly from that
and if you're used to using the
concurrent Futures interface then it's
just a very very small step
to use many computers for that like the
distributed approach to do things and
there
the newest kid in town probably is to
ask
and that's what I've brought with me
today like a very small Raspberry Pi
based cluster which is doing all these
things you might have a look at it later
on
and you can start using dusk on your
local machine it also follows the
concurrent Futures interface the idea
being to
split your work into pieces map your
function performing the work and putting
all things together afterwards
and then you can if that works scale out
use many clusters
you have to start your cluster by
a helper function you have to prepare it
like your Security based login should
work
you should use the same architecture on
these things but then fun begins all you
need to change from going local to
remotely is to use that scheduler
address and then you're good to go
and then you can enjoy the wonderful Das
dashboard and follow what work has been
done for you all day and that is really
literally what you can stay on it's very
very satisfying to do so
so that brings me sadly to the end time
is left and so what is to say what is
the idea
I can think of
three scenarios I think where where you
can look at one being you have your
local machine and you should accelerate
on that
then go for concurrent futures
learn how you can divide and conquer and
have some fun
next thing is the GPU and then you can
benefit that most libraries today
resemble the same interface and make it
easy for you to switch once you're used
to using numpy it will be easy to use
the rest
and then there is a thing where you have
many nodes around you can persuade your
management to to buy in
and then probably dusk is the the first
thing to go because you came from that
strategy from going to concurrent
Futures and then you can scale out
and that's all I've got to say today so
thank you very much for for listening
being here
and then open
for questions
and probably and hopefully have answers
a couple of questions uh actually as a
starter what tool did you use for the
presentation I was hoping someone was
asking for that
um that is Jupiter book
so the idea being
um to use a missed markdown
and all I did when you read when you
reading docs like literally read the
docs then mostly you see a structure
like that with all the table of contents
involved and the pages there all I need
to do was have a little CSS to make the
phones larger and
make it look like slides probably
hopefully people will have an eye on
that and support this more natively in
the future that will be cruel
um so the next question would be what
are some examples that you could use the
idea of fractals to solve some real
world problems no not a single one and
the idea is that this is a very simple
way to do generate arbitrary workloads
easily
and that is for me it's an ideal an
ideal
candidate for exploring the
properties that a system like like the
Raspberry Pi cluster has when you have
an idea how the formula works and how
they work on a single machine is things
change drastically if you go for
distributed
approaches like this because you have
the network bandwidth involved all the
communication and management over it
involved and you need to play with these
things to get an idea what the best
setup would be if you do this with
production code and strategies it might
be two or three steps too far already
this is a very manageable and easy setup
so that's where I started
okay thank you the next one would be how
do you figure out that you're being
naive and miss something and how do you
balance that with over a complex over
complexification say it again
how do I figure out how being naive like
how do you know when you're being naive
about your implementation and how do you
find out
so first of all I love native code
because it is so easy to follow you can
literally read English text in poison to
see what's going on
and
it for for many people it's like code
smell if they see that
because they know better ways how to do
things
but if you start off with the most
efficient implementations first
you get a hard time and debugging
probably
so I tend to start with many for loops
to see what's going on there's a very
simple way to accelerate if that's
necessary actually number has the best
options on naive code
it will be the easy it's hard for number
two
accelerate efficient Solutions like
using numpy for example
but numpy is the next step that I that I
use because everything else resembles
the API so if it comes from for
numerical calculations that's that's my
way
thank you one question would be whether
the notebooks are accessible after your
talk they will I will put everything in
a GitHub repository I'll find a way to
to post where to find everything because
there's lots more here that we didn't
have to cover time to cover
okay
um one more a non-nvidia gpus also
supported by some libraries actually yes
there
is things going on for for Apple for
example and the AMD chips and apple
silicon with the uh with a metal back
end it's supported by some libraries
but for
reasons that I don't really understand
most things really focus on on Nvidia
that's that's rather sad actually
yeah for many reasons
um and the last one very inspiring do
you know polars and have you tried it
yeah sure
um it is a complete different Beast I
think
polars for me at least I see it in the
context of pandas and replacing Panda so
if if I organize data in a table format
that's that's the pretty much the thing
to go forward
not really in that context here okay
thank you so much again for the talk and
here